nach leipzig geil und weißt du was du
weisst du liebst es ja die
online-community lied oh ja ich habe
wieder quiz vorbereitet
zeig mal was machen wir jetzt nicht wir
müssen jetzt mal ein bisschen in die
tiefe gehen so realistisch wäre nicht so
larifari gegeben für einen soziologen
und der der erklärt uns jetzt das
phänomen afd
alles klar
[Musik]
vor mir
so jetzt mal schön dass sie sich noch
mal mehr professor wir wollen heute über
die alv die reden über fgbl wogegen
protestiert denn jemand der die kfd welt
also was wir wissen ist das thema
flüchtlingskrise hat den leuten wirklich
nicht geschmeckt
sie möchten keine multikulturelle
gesellschaft also schon relativ werden
nichtdeutsche noch dann ja dann gibt's
nun institutionen misstrauen nennen wir
das also die eliten was die ihre
demokratie machen das ist nicht so
transparent das gefällt nicht da muss
man mal in berlin zeigen dass das wieder
so nicht weitermachen können ist es so
dass viele cdu wähler dazu in die arbeit
der ft geflüchtet sind und suchen so ein
bisschen die rechte haltung und wissen
nicht wo sie sonst hingehen soll die
frau merkel hat gesagt meine politik ist
alternativlos und ich bin der meinung
der meinung bin ich nicht wenn sie an
die abschaffung der wehrpflicht denken
ja das ende der atomkraft beispielsweise
die einstellung zur homo-ehe
all das sind dinge die wand für die cdu
in den 80er jahren völlig undenkbar die
fdp ist schon die einzige partei die wir
auf dem politischen markt sehen die ganz
klar sagt wir wollen mehr dazu neustart
wir wollen vor allen dingen auch weniger
migration haben und da hat man jetzt
also weder nicht so wahnsinnig viel
auswahl wenn man der partei haben will
die auf eine chance hat im parlament zu
sein
wir wissen ja zum beispiel auch dass in
ostdeutschland wie in der relativ
geringen anteil von migranten haben die
erleben
eine emigranten was schätzen sie denn
wie hoch ist der ausländeranteil in
brandenburg 40 prozent und wir wissen je
mehr migranten in einer stadt leben
desto liberaler sind ist die bevölkerung
insgesamt gegenüber migration
aufgeschlossen was glauben sie denn die
altparteien falsch gemacht im umgang mit
den ostdeutschen
also ich gebe immer ein beispiel wir
wissen dass in ostdeutschland die afg ja
viel stärker ist als in westdeutschland
dann schau mal bisschen genauer hin und
stellen fest naja was unterscheidet denn
die landesteile etwas was man so in der
wissenschaft strukturschwäche nimmt das
heißt die läden sind alle zu es gibt
auch kein supermarkt
der konsum macht zu die kaufhalle der
landarzt wird nicht mehr wieder besetzt
die bahn schließt ihr letztes häuschen
und ihre dorf station und das nehmen die
leute als eine form von benachteiligung
war als eine form von rückschritt wo sie
sich tatsächlich benachteiligt führen
und sagen ihr könnt uns hier nicht
hängen lassen was kann man da machen
also wirklich man kann natürlich auch
hingehen und sagen wir machen jetzt zu
anders also wenn sie da gegensteuern
werden müssen sie die leute ernst nehmen
und müssen versuchen infrastrukturell
dagegenzuhalten in der tat müssen sich
was überlegen wie sie landärzte zum
ansiedeln bewegen
damit ihnen nicht in die großstädte
ziehen sondern eben ausland wäre eine
möglichkeit sehr teuer schwierig man
kann ja niemanden zwingen
aber damit die versorgung auf dem land
tatsächlich sichergestellt ist ich habe
jetzt total spannendes und ausgedacht ja
wir sind klasse ab die wir sind aus
deutsches pärchen
ich bin natürlich der mann also ich bin
ich bin mandy oder du bist mein handy
ich würde jetzt sagen warum ich die fdp
wählen und sie könnten an gestimmt das
ist das ist da was dran an der these
oder ist es quatsch ich glaube dass die
ausländer mit meinen job wegnehmen
dass sich afg wieder bedroht fühlen vor
arbeitslosigkeit kann die forschung so
nicht bestätigen
also ich will auch afd weil wir haben
diese und das ist gut ist ein guter
diese und und wir haben eine ofenheizung
dann ist uns auch haben und ja wir
wollen auch weiter verteuern dürften wir
wollen weiterhin im diesel durch
erzgebirge brettern ja ihr wählt afd
weil ihr nichts gegen den klimawandel
tun wollt oder was den gibt's doch gar
nicht gibt auch okay das ist eine klare
these vermutlich ist das so auch da
können wir nicht 100 prozent sagen aber
wir haben den eindruck dass unter afd
wlan häufiger klimawandel leugner sind
als unter anderen parteien und die
protagonisten der partei die sagen das
ja auch ne menschen macht hat immer
wandel sind wir uns nicht so sicher
halten wir für unfug
und das ist etwas was afd wieder
glaubwürdig finden
also wenn er nach hause kommt dann habe
ich dann tofu schnitzel gemacht ging er
sich nicht entschlüsselt er sich nicht
ja was sollte ich kann doch nicht offen
backen für den markt man hätte ja weiß
ich noch nicht was wahrscheinlicher ist
es nicht ja woher soll ich wissen sie
noch zeit sich jetzt zu trennen
es ist zeit sich zu trennen
wir müssen uns doch trennen ich bin ja
wirklich ein optimistischer mensch und
glaube immer an das gute aber bei euch
beiden glaube ich dass hopfen malz
verloren
ihr solltet getrennte wege gehen
demokratie wird einem nicht geschenkt
für die demokratie muss man arbeiten und
jetzt aber trotzdem nicht
soll ich jetzt noch was essen oder nicht
wir machen rechte angst wo sind die
rechten
darf die einfach nicht fehlen fertig aus
[Musik]
es ist nicht toll dann wird nicht mehr
verschwinden wie bleibt und ansonsten
ist das ein wunderschönes land mit
wunderschönen menschen die sehen wir
nicht auch noch besser als entfernt
fabian ich habe den osten unterschätzt
ich muss sagen eigentlich war es doch
ganz schön klar wir haben paar echte
getroffen aber insgesamt waren die
menschen doch recht herzlich ich habe
mich wohl gefühlt ist echt schade dass
wir jetzt wieder zurück nach köln müssen
aber ich muss mir dann zurück nach
cannes
mic
[Musik]
du hast recht mandy
lasst uns hier leben
[Musik]
ja